what's behind the rise in so-called
bandit attacks in northern nigeria
gunmen kill at least 200 people
reportedly in retaliation for government
airstrikes can anything stop the cycle
of violence
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum armed groups have
terrorized people in central and
northwestern nigeria for years the
so-called bandits burned down villages
steal cattle and kidnap people for
ransom attacks are on the rise and the
government appears to be struggling to
stop them
at least 200 people were killed in
zamfara state last tuesday witnesses say
gunmen on motorbikes attacked eight
villages the assault appears to be
retaliation for military airstrikes a
day earlier on the bandits hideouts in
nearby forests
separately security forces in zamfara
rescued nearly 100 hostages abducted
three months ago the police chief says
the operation involved airstrikes and in
kebbi state further west 30 students
were freed after seven months it's
unclear whether ransoms were paid
the violence is rooted in a conflict for
land and water between nomadic cattle
herders and farmers who come from
different ethnic groups but criminal
gangs have become more involved in the
past few years
they have extorted millions of dollars
from kidnappings some security analysts
call it the most lucrative industry in
nigeria
the president has labeled the gang's
terrorist organizations this allows the
military to deploy more force and the
government can seek international
support to fight the armed groups
all right let's bring in our guests in
abuja mike edufour former director of
nigeria's state security service in
london bulama bucharti senior analyst at
the tony blair institute for global
change and in coventry aliyu musa
independent researcher focusing on war
and conflict in nigeria a warm welcome
to you all and thanks for joining us on
inside story today bulama let me start
with you were these attacks by armed
bandits in zamfara state in response to
the airstrikes that were conducted last
week by the military against armed
bandits
i mean that's what the military says and
nigeria's president calls it a desperate
attack but this is the line from
government whenever we see attacks like
this this has been the narrative for
over five years but if you say these
were desperate uh people who have under
a serious military attack
they marched into five different
villages and operated for 48 hours
i would think if they were desperate
they should be throwing out their
weapons and hiding themselves not
matching into villages and killing 200
people
and we know that this killing of 200
people is a big number
but
the statistics show that at least 50
people are killed in the northwestern
part of nigeria every single week and
this has been the case over the past uh
i mean 12 15 months last year alone in
2021
10
and a half 000 nigerians were killed and
over 50 percent of them were killed in
the northwest and
four and a half thousand nigerians that
is 4 500 people were kidnapped some of
them have been released after they have
paid ransom others have been killed and
some are still in custody even
colleagues of the 30 students you said
on the top
that were released yesterday 18
students
uh consisting of 15 girls and three boys
and are still in custody and they have
been in custody for seven long months
now so i don't think it is a desperate
attack it is not a [ __ ] retaliatory
attack because they were not attacked by
villagers in any case they were attacked
by military jets and so if there were
attacks on if there are attacks on
villages then these are horrific
terroristic attacks on innocent
nigerians that we should not type
retaliatory or desperate
mike the term bandit is used often to
describe these armed groups and their
members but i'm wondering if that term
is too simple if that term belies how
sophisticated these criminal gangs are
how powerful they have become i wonder
if you could dissect for our audience
who exactly are these bandits i mean who
makes up these groups and how did they
emerge
well you see the issue in the northwest
you see they started as a
you know we
all the bandits because
they're involved in criminalities
uh but it became worrisome that they got
to the point of
being masculine of school children
abduction raping of women and
the government had to take further steps
you know by
based on the plumber from the people to
at least
designate them as terrorists which is
what they are because they have so much
created fear in the in the people that
economic activities have brought to your
heart people are no more no longer safe
they don't move through the freely so i
think it's a right step in the right
direction that government
did dismiss them as a terrorist and they
haven't done that i think the government
is now on the offensive you recall that
it was not easy to deploy the chicanos
uh pilot because of the law in the u.s
which prohibits the sale of
arms
to nigeria because of uh
human rights allegiance abuse
but now that
they've been designated as terrorists
they'll be treated as terrorists i think
that's what government is doing
based on intelligence
their locations are looking uh
found out and
the air force will go after them to
bombard the areas and possibly flush
them out
and i think that is responsible for the
recent attacks
i i want to say is
retaliatory you know because they are
being
pounded and
switched out from their homes they are
now going after innocent civilians
ali you heard mike there talk about the
fact that it was just last week that the
government has
designated officially these armed groups
these bandits as terrorists so the
government says that this is going to
enable them uh to go after these groups
in a more efficient manner to go after
the groups to go after their
sympathizers um do you think that's the
case do you think this designation of
these groups these bandits as terrorists
will actually improve the situation
well i think um
calling them terrorists is something
that is actually related
um from day one
these guys
were terrorists
the government shouldn't have waited
this long to call them
what they are they have always been
terrorists
and um let me add to what um my
colleague mike pfos just
said about them
um
what we need to understand about this
group of criminals is that um
uh we need to understand that they are
three categories of criminals
first of all
um
they are
bandits
who are
political criminals political criminals
in the sense that
uh many of them
are
have have nothing really to do with um
farmer's head
crisis
they were thoughts that are being used
by politicians
and now
being dumped or further being used as
proxies this has been confirmed by by by
even the governor of the state who is
presently helpless
and he's saying it that yes there are
strong politicians who are using them
imagine one of the criminals tooji
he's there he's crossing a lot of mayhem
in the states but he can't be arrested
he is responsible for uh
for for the killings of over 200 people
in a boss on the bus they were benched
but she can be arrested
um this is one set of the criminals
another set of the criminals is um
a group of the the the the headers now
these are people
that originally had problems with the
farmers
so you can understand that that's
part of the problem started between
from a clash between the farmers and the
headers and because there was no
government intervention at the beginning
that continued
until where we are today
then there is also a movement of
criminals from the northeast
who originally
were
boko haram terrorists
and they moved on from the north pace
down to the northwest because the
government's strategy of dealing with
the terrorists in the northwest was not
properly fell safe
first step in the sense that
whereas when you are fighting criminals
you have to deal with it in such a way
that when you disperse them you don't
let them i mean when you fight them you
don't let them dispass all of you
i'm sorry i'm sorry to interrupt you let
me get back to you in just a moment on
on that point that you're making right
now i do have a question about that
first i want to go to bulama because
bulama you heard aliyo there talk about
some of the historical roots of the
conflict that we're seeing play out in
northwestern nigeria this violence seems
to be rooted in conflict for land and
water between nomadic cattle herders and
and farmers and i want to ask you more
about that if you could walk our viewers
through a bit of the history of this
conflict and how it's playing out and if
you think it's only going to be
worsening at least in the short term
yeah i mean
so the conflict originally started as a
farmer had a crisis and cattle rustling
and that is because there was this
competition over scarce water and resort
and land resources in the northwestern
part of nigeria but also across the
country i remember growing up in the
northeast we have always seen these
conflicts uh
rare in their heads whenever it is rainy
season where you have farmers and
hardest fighting but then like ali said
in the course of time then criminals
inserted themselves into the field and
they took over almost uh the whole
crisis in the north west especially in
the last 10 years or so and what we saw
was this growing business of kidnapping
for ransom and as you said on the top it
is the most lucrative industry in
nigeria today it is the biggest business
giving
the largest amount of profit you can
think of now then of course there was
infiltration by boko haram fighters but
that's a very
little portion of what we are talking
about what we are talking about in the
northwest today are an estimated a group
of an estimated 30 000 criminals divided
into over 100 guns and what they do is
to kidnap people uh burn down villages
and i completely agree with allu that
their designation is long overdue they
should have been designated long ago but
even now that they have been designated
except the government takes steps and
treats them like terrorists has declined
declaring them terrorists won't solve
the problem they have got to be treated
and before like terrorists are being
fought in other parts of nigeria
mike are these uh bandits are these
armed groups in any way linked to boko
haram or has boko haram infiltrated them
in any way
well it cannot be fully established but
like
the other part of my colleague said you
know when they dispersed on the notice
the tendency for them to move to the
northwest which increased the temple
although it's coming established but i
believe that
in addition to the original bandits
within the northwest especially zafar
state for instance
they did not have
more support
and
they are not encouraged because of the
rights of being paid
by victims and they it it helps them
more to accumulate
more uh money to buy their weapons like
you said in your entry you see millions
of dollars
of naira are paid
[Music]
there's a possibility that those of them
from the northeast has increased the
strength of the death in the northwest
but with this new onslaught having been
designated their terrorists i think the
government will go out and
fish them out and possibly restore
normalcy in that area ali you were
speaking a moment ago about different
criminal elements and how the government
is combating them i i also want to ask
you a little bit about boko haram
in combating boko haram in going after
boko haram has the government
essentially dropped the ball when it
comes to going after other criminal
gangs or other bandits in different
parts of the country
well i don't think really um
so much has been done particularly
in the case of um
this uh criminal in the north peace in
the northwest uh particularly if you
look at what is happening right now in
uh zamfara state
uh
like i mentioned i have mentioned the
case of uh
toruji who is a criminal there unlike my
colleague bullama has mentioned uh we
have a lot of criminals there
the most
creative business today in nigeria is
kidnapping for ransom you can imagine
people negotiating with criminals every
day
criminals asking for millions of
millions of naira to to to to to release
human beings and the government is
watching
in some prostate alone
they impose taxes on villagers
people who haven't got money somebody
will have to go out and go and look for
money in the city to come and pick
criminals but government is watching
there so i what i'm saying is
the government's calling them terrorists
would not change anything unless they
change their strategy of discrimination
yeah the military can't just go there
and bomb them uh from the air and then
without really uh putting down ground
soldiers to make sure that the whole
place is fighting you have to seal the
whole place and stop them from getting
out
because what is happening
go ahead ali you sorry
yeah what is happening is that when you
bomb the place and you let them get out
you are endangering the villagers more
because you are letting them go to come
back and attack the villages and then
you call them you call that desperate
resolution no that shouldn't be
happening
let me let me ask you to pick up on a
point that uh aliyu was making there um
you know it's been reported that in
recent weeks nigerian military has
increased airstrikes on forest hideouts
in parts of zamfara
is there any evidence that they have
been effective
i mean
it is true that the nigerian military
has increased or escalated air strikes
but we also know that these criminals
have over the years mastered the the art
of evading air strikes the nigerian
military has been a striking boko haram
for over six years now in fact about
eight years now but boko haram is still
wreaking havoc in the northeastern part
of nigeria and in the northwest we have
seen military air strikes for example in
the first quarter of last year that's
2021. in kaduna state the nigerian
military rain air strike for three
months
and in their own report in the
government's report they said in the
three months they did air strike for
they killed only 67 criminals 67 of 30
or 30 000 criminals
we know that they are masters of evading
air strikes and the military will come
and rent bombs and then leave the area
only for them to get out of the uh of
the jungles and attack innocent
nigerians and the fact that the military
withdraws after those air strikes just
like we have seen in this attack we are
talking about where over 200 people were
killed you know that it is ineffective
you have got to
get
on the ground and air i mean cooperation
but also there is need for a better
cooperation between nigeria and new
jersey public because we know that when
there are onslaughts major military
onslaught the criminals have found a way
of
clean nigeria's territory into nigeria
republic only for them to return to
nigeria after the military has finished
wasting its resources and so it is not
effective and the last few years are
clear that it hasn't been effective
mike from your vantage point as the
former director of nigeria state
security service let me ask you do you
believe that the scope of the military
operations as they are playing out now
are too narrow and that in order for
them to be effective going forward they
really need to widen them out and cover
more territory especially forest
territory where these bandits and these
armed groups may be hiding out
yeah i think uh it's good to huge result
because uh first of all you see uh they
haven't been designated terrorists who
have to change
uh tactical uh tactical approach to
these
uh
like
i said earlier you don't
normally they might be collateral damage
but with intensified intelligence i
think their exact locations will be
spotted and
on their way out coming up for attack
because that is the problem the question
has been
where our security agencies when these
people are coming out until they are
back at the retreat you begin to pursue
that it becomes very difficult for you
to
[Music]
carry out any attack on their work while
their hostages so with this new
offensive that their exam locations
where they are coming they are bombed
but the fear again is that uh they will
take it against the civilian populace
but this war is a war that must be won
the government must take the initiative
from uh these bandits and their
restoracy in that area i think that's
the position ali how do these various
types of attacks and the types of
kidnappings uh that have been going on
how have they impacted schools and
students in different communities and
how have these attacks impacted trade
routes as well
well um
like we know right from the days of boko
haram up until now
schools have been the targets
we know schools have been attacked in
the past and we know how much um schools
and presently have been attacked
students kidnapped um
as we speak now
there are students from
baptist school in kaduna
that i have been in a captivity for
probably three months going i mean to
four months or so um there were schools
of uh an islamic school which is uh i
mean they're just like kindergartens
that were taken away and they were in
captivity for for more than
three months
nobody could even pay the ransom and get
them out they were there for several
months some of them died
there as we speak there are schools that
there are students are from
the one um higher institution i can't
remember the name
that were
kidnapped and then they were there they
are still there as we speak
so it is a major problem
when you send your children to school
you get worried what is going to happen
to them they get killed or they get
kidnapped a number of students of
universities on their way to university
or on their way to
university trips uh kind of school trips
they get relayed by this criminals
and taken away a number of times bombs
go off and they get killed and so on we
remember the chibok story and that the
duchy story what happened in the case of
boko haram then just kidnapped us today
so what i find very difficult to
understand is why these criminals are
doing this uh by attacking schools but
then when you look at it
boko haram really succeeded
and
for a number of years boko haram was
trying to write describe his name on the
world map they couldn't succeed even
after bombing the un building but then
it's succeeded easily by getting uh into
chibok so school
by attacking schools by making schools
and students victims i think um they can
easily draw international attention so
school it's very easy to understand why
schools can be affected and in terms of
trade economy
not has been affected
significantly uh businesses have been
crippled particularly the farmers they
cannot harvest
most of the time they will have to pay
taxes impose of them and impose on them
when they cannot even if they are unable
to pay those taxes it means the whole of
the crops that have been
that ideal for harvesting they get
wasted
and
that means
there is no crops for the next uh season
to be sold
and uh a lot of money is wasted and then
business rules
are blocked completely because when you
are on the way you try to travel you get
uh you end up in their hands and these
are massless people so yeah
how are you
how are you
i'm so sorry to interrupt you again we
are starting to run out of time uh
bulama my last question uh to you
i want to talk for a moment about the
survivors of of these attacks uh the
most recent attack in zamfara and
previous attacks as well
do we know how many people have been
left homeless um are they able to
receive the necessary help and aid that
they need i mean just how traumatized
are these populations by what they've
been through
i mean uh the population is uh highly
traumatized and we are talking about
children who have spent months at the
hands of at the hands of horrific
criminals some girls are raped in the
name of forced marriage and then when
they return back to the communities
there is hardly any social uh i mean
psychosocial support or mental support
that is given to them we also know that
in just one state zamfara state there
are about 700 000 internally displaced
people and there is no come to to
shelter them there is no food there is
no medication
and so people are just sleeping on the
roadside motor garages are in in places
human beings shouldn't be sleeping
especially in this fight fighting winter
and so you have that but schools are
over 500 schools are right now shut down
in zamfara there is no primary school or
secondary school that has opened in the
last five months but the same thing is
it is the case across other northwestern
states where uh schools have partly been
shut down and in the northeastern part
of nigeria and so nigerian children
especially northern nigerian children
are left behind when other children
across the world and in nigeria are
getting educated
i'm sorry to interrupt you but we have
run out of time so we're going to have
to leave the conversation there thank
you so much to all of our guests mike
edgio for bulama bukarti and aliyu musa
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jroom and the whole team
here bye for now
[Music]
you